>> Brian: ALL RIGHT, LET'S SEND
IT DOWN TO STEPHANIE READY.
SHE'S GOT TRAE YOUNG.
>> Stephanie: TRAE, HERE WE ARE
AGAIN.
YOU ALL MADE A COMEBACK, SEVERAL
RUNS, DOUBLE DIGITS IN THE
FOURTH QUARTER.
WHAT HAPPENED?
>> WE KEPT FIGHTING.
THIS TEAM, I HAVE BEEN SAYING IT
ALL YEAR, ALL PLAYOFFS, WE KEEP
FIGHTING.
NO MATTER WHAT THE SCORE IS, NO
MATTER IF WE'RE DOWN OR UP,
WE'RE GOING TO FIGHT.
I'M PROUD OF THIS TEAM BECAUSE
WE KEEP ON FIGHTING.
>> Stephanie: WHAT IS THAT LIKE
IN THE HUDDLES DOWN THE STRETCH
WHEN YOU LOOK UP AND YOU'RE DOWN
20 POINTS AND STILL HAVE ENOUGH
CONFIDENCE IN EACH OTHER?
>> LIKE I SAID, WE HAVE
CONFIDENCE IN EACH OTHER.
WE'RE A GREAT GROUP, A GREAT
GROUP TO BE AROUND.
WE ALL LOVE EACH OTHER'S COMPANY
AND IT SHOWS ON THE COURT.
WE NEVER STOP BELIEVING UNTIL
THE FINAL BUZZER GOES OFF.
>> Stephanie: COACH McMILLAN
TRUSTS YOU IMPLICITLY.
HE SAYSU CALLING PLAYS DOWN THE
STRETCH.
WHAT'S IT LIKE KNOWING YOU'RE IN
CONTROL OF WHAT HAPPENS?
>> IT'S GREAT.
I HAVE A COACH THAT TRUSTS ME
AND TRUSTS I'M GOING PUT OUR
TEAM IN THE BEST POSITION TO
WIN, AND I'M STILL LEARNING.
I STILL HAVE A LOT TO LEARN, A
LOT TO GET BETTER AT, BUT I
THINK WE'RE IN A BETTER PLACE
AND WE HAVE TO --
>> Stephanie: THANKS A LOT,
APPRECIATE IT.
>> Brian: 39 POINTS, STEPH.
HE'S GOT FIVE 30-PLUS POINT ROAD
GAMES IN THIS PLAYOFF.
109-106, THE HAWKS COME BACK AND
SHOCK T